there's certainly no reason that private
farms couldn't run all the toll roads in
the United States
my name is Bruce Benson I'm an economics
professor Florida State University and
chairman of the department most of my
research focuses on private alternatives
to public production of various things
like roads and police there are many
examples of private roads both
historically and and today in fact today
there are many more private roads I
think that most people imagine even
though many of them drive on them and
live next to them in the United States
private roads were everywhere
essentially historically there were many
privately built roads that were not toll
roads many local communities who wanted
to get connected into the system of
trade and in commerce with other
communities built connecting roads one
of my favorite modern examples is in st.
Louis Missouri where the city government
actually deeded roads back to local
communities these local neighborhoods of
two three four blocks request a to get
the control of the roads back from the
city the city grants them a deed in
exchange of course they have to maintain
the road and and those sorts of things
but it becomes their roads and they can
limit access to them if they want to put
up speed bumps and they also of course
are a lot more attentive to who's on the
road when they own it because they can
tell somebody leave if they don't like
them being there we also see
increasingly especially in developing
countries now the government essentially
is franchising roads by arranging with a
private company to build and maintain
the roads and then charge tolls there's
certainly no reason that private firms
couldn't run all the toll roads in the
United States for instance
and many more government roads are for
the most part free access roads that
means anyone with a car can get on them
or a truck they don't have to pay the
cost that they impose on other people or
on the road itself we all pay gasoline
taxes but there's no direct link between
that and the roads and the minds of most
people so we treat these roads as what
economists would call free access common
pools that means we're not paying the
price so we use them too much we crowd
them we have tremendous congestion the
congestion issues is going to be a big
one a lot of people of course are afraid
to think about that in that because they
don't want to have to pay the tolls we
all like the free ride I don't like
paying for things either but I would
suggest also that there won't be tolls
everywhere I the st. louis community
example is an example of private roads
with no tolls local communities where
the benefits of the roads are internal
to the community will create the roads
themselves or maintain the roads
themselves there will be I'm I'm more
than willing to permit or predict that
there will be roads created by groups or
Fong's who want people to come to their
location so you will have roads built
intentionally probably by prop I could
imagine Las Vegas for instance wanting
people to have easy access to from Los
Angeles so the casinos get together and
build a nice road connecting Los Angeles
and Las Vegas they may not charge tolls
it'll be a direct probably much quicker
route to Las Vegas and so individuals
and firms and organizations who want to
capture benefits from kraid or other
sorts of interactions
certainly have incentives to create
roads that will bring the traffic they
want I would suggest however that a
system of private roads would probably
toll roads in this case with
long-distance travel trying to get
around the country would end up being
more efficient because for one thing
they don't have to take big swings in
order to go through some town that some
senator wants it to go through I grew up
in Montana if you look at Interstate 90
it goes into Wyoming then shoots up into
Montana to go further west why
well Montana had some very powerful
senators so you have a road system
that's influenced not just by the need
to get certain places but by the
political pressures from various
powerful groups a private road system is
going to get you from here to there more
efficiently they'll be less congested
there I could even see specialized roads
for different kinds of travel certainly
between big cities you know there could
be a a private road for people who want
to drive fast between New York and
Chicago or something like that
another one for trucks and motorhomes a
maybe one that has a minimum speed
others that have a maximum speed
the possibilities really given the
sufficient demand are endless I don't
think people are going to have less
convenience under a private system I
would suspect it'd be more